i giri e te ne vai affanculo ok bella
senti ragazzi e benvenuti questo video
sono vaghi j
oggi siamo in un nuovo horror con la q
lustri per ragazzi erano un secolo che
mi facciamo un horror coi contro maroni
con loculo swift e non mi mancavi tanto
sta cosa però si possono osservare dalle
promesse reca perché tanto sono ritardi
ray soltanto la mia morte quindi
iniziamo a chi è bello quando quando
iniziano i giochi così ragazzi è
bellissimo e nel caso della madonna che
cazzo è successo io ho sempre detto di
non saltare sul letto cazzola cui
succedono ste cose però va bene va bene
che abbiamo avanti che non importa altro
non so sto gioco volevo dirvi che è
stato catalogato come uno dei peggiori
in assoluto dior
era questo perfetto seleziona un piano
piano uno dei manager piano due
all'ospedale piano 3 carnival tutti
molto allegri devo dire che ne di
partire da the carnival giusto perché
grazie molto molto accogliente ragazzi
veramente figo organici messi è piano
terra grazie proprio nella lobby ma i
servizi in camera in questo hotel c'è
attenzione non fare questo esperimento
con la luce non giocare da solo e già è
già due sono andato a [ __ ] senti
senti male di nuovi il locus
immediatamente perfette ragazzi ci ha
appena detto che ce l'abbiamo nel comune
né cosa veramente [ __ ] soprattutto salve
questa è camera via suppongo avevo
chiesto una suite ormai è bello però
come era sulle recensioni su internet se
la ue si salverà ma da madonna qui c'è
un corridoio e che cazzo se ogni volta
che gioco pasticcio di qui sento fiero
linee stesso dato perché manca un quadro
qui complimenti per la musica perché di
sottofondo spark saleh sentite io io io
avrei bisogno del cameriere chi ha
chiesto lascia così disordine assistono
anzi ne è passato ancora la cameriera
dopo che allora sono successe due cose
strane uno sto camminando nel nulla e 2
sia per tosta porta bellissimo giorno
seen things torso io so camminare nel
vuoto quindi posso
porca [ __ ] porca [ __ ] cazzo ha
chiuso la porta che stavo scherzando
quando prima dove cazzo siamo non era
così prima che chi è che ha rovinato il
muro porca [ __ ] avevo chiesto una
[ __ ] suite abcde cominciare buchiamo
dei fantasmi da già che ci siamo mi
posso portarmi in estintore in azzurro
perché sia per tosta porta quindi si va
bene che ha ma che cazzo si va nel peso
alte giorno ho sentito
no no no no no va bene che questo e
questo è pesantissimo seriamente cagando
addosso di qua perfetto ascolta io io io
e vengo in panne o rompere i [ __ ] so
già che c'è qualcuno che apre le porte
che sradica le porte soprattutto ciao
ciao ciao a tutti sì sì sì sì bella
festa che chi è che ha portato il
crodino che io avevo al pensando ci
torno anche a casa buongiorno e questo
non è un posto per bambini perché quasi
ci sono adulti che bevono sto tizio un
figo della madonna tipe bei quadri ogni
comune contro 1 grazie bello stop the
year the killer è perché ho visto
qualcuno passa di là guardami le spalle
che hai fortunatamente c'abbiamo jack
che ci aiuta poi sono col cazzo permesso
ma io non posso andare avanti così però
abbiate pazienza
cos'è
porca [ __ ] porca [ __ ] si è aperta la
porta non sono stato io
andate a cagare jeff ascolto un attimo
così chiuso la porta dietro [ __ ]
si è mosso immobile non so voi ma è una
cosa che a me non succede molto spesso
in casa quindi torri a uscire di qui
quindi grazie
cos'è cos'è stato che si trova su itunes
questa belle belle sedie mia nonna cela
uguali giuro
cos'è sta roba perché c'era un letto un
letto fatemi andare a dormire perché non
posso legge ma ciao
ascoltami no no no non scherzo scherzo
ascoltami piccolina mia non è che vai
caso mi spieghi che cosa sta succedendo
la lega non ma vicino io ti dico dove
trovare dei quadri bellissimi e tu mi
dici dove l'uscita
se andate affatto una corsa veloce e
bellissimo grazie di questa bellissima
accoglienza ha attivato la è ok se tutto
è stato molto bello veramente figo
soprattutto il cardion bellissimo perché
cazzo cielos lander man sul muro anche
puoi metterti anche da è un gioco di
merda ma vabbè si può andare di qualche
ha permesso
ripensandoci io torno indietro grazie ai
ragazzi se siamo tutti in una stanzina
ci raccontiamo un po di storia ed ios e
possibilmente non horror e perché avevo
detto di guardarmi il culo prima ma
tanto a fare affidamento su di te come
fare affidamento su un carciofo non è
che possa così un altro un altro non ne
bastava uno prima
[Applauso]
chi è che ha messo skrillex asta porta
si è aperta a caso le prime mi hai detto
che non c'era nessuno però si è acceso
brutto ragazzi sono un muro è
bruttissimo cos'è poiché ci sono scatole
vuote ragazzi jeffrey j
il frigo in frigo chi è che si è rubato
la nutella bastard 10 frigoriferi e non
non uno che abbia la nutella ore
bastardi proprio piccola che cos'è
successo
questo è successo c'è chi ha preso la
mia nutella stronzi cioè la posta
probabilmente c'è una lettera però guai
non lo so non mi piace il posto sentite
può allora io questa portata
no non farò io non posso tre ragazzi
cosa che posso brutto è questo mio dio
sì ma leggermente un pò d'ordine con gli
scaffali e per cortesia
tu sei sul rumore brutto perché se in
questo rumore brutto di sottofondo
ragazzi per favore ma se chi è che ha
ucciso la sedia
qualcosa non mi piace rumore non mi
piace oddio vivo dubitavate di me era un
altro a tavola wii cioè basta però è un
altro slider manson muro ma che cazzo
ascoltate lega non è che posso passare
la vita di di qua di qua vado di qua
perfetto grazie a vento dei pazzi
protoni oggi attrae aste forte porca
[ __ ] ho trovato una bambina ancora
stata votato no giovanni mi fanno
pisciare si quadri bellissima
non ho visto un cazzo non ho visto un
car agazzi che cos'è la prima volta
nella storia un importo che prendono non
lo vedo scortate da galan non è che
posso avere gente che mi cammina in
faccia mentre gioca un horror e
soprattutto questo cos'è e l'uscita
quella sono fa vj sto andando all'uscita
per che minaccia il sensore st porta
fosse una porta maniglia invece ci avrà
il sensore che si apre bella la sedia a
rega capiamo madonna che wingardium sta
minkia se mania di grandezza di voi
sedie non le sopporto quindi scendi
grazie ragazzi
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
non vi è chi ha ucciso le sedie che
volavano ragazzi e che ha ucciso le
sedie ok chiave sulla porta bastardi
bastardi ma io lo so che jeffrey a lo so
è che quel pezzo di merda
hai rotto i [ __ ] tu non ti giri e te
ne vai affanculo la [ __ ] di tua madre
che cuba i gelati in questo posto di
merda parto ancora dove siamo dove si sa
cos'è perché sentivo male l'ascensore
sono morto non sono morto non si può
morire in un gioco così spero era
assente non indietro bello bello mi
piace sta quando non avete capito un
cazzo io non me li vi farò mai nella
vita gli altri karma mai proprio che
fanno anche il 2d sto gioco si chiama
affected 2 feb in una casa allora
ragazzi abbiamo ancora piano 2
l'ospedale e piano 3 il carnevale
possano morire tutti bruciati per questo
episodio concludo qui non perché sono
giusto un po morto così seguito è
piaciuto lasciato argomento mi piace
anche a faccia di facebook e come negli
anni ho trovato nelle scrizione sono
sindacalisti discreti lì ci dividiamo
nel prossimo video spero non troppo
presto bella ragazzi
[Musica]